these Trump's former White House chief
strategist and the co-host of the war
room impeachment and war room pandemic
podcast Steve Benin has agreed to come
by again
brave man Steve thank you for doing this
thank you for being polite okay
Steve so look I'm not gonna lie about it
your boy had the best week so far don't
you think was the last two weeks I think
you see the culmination all right I
admitted it don't gloat but I think this
shows you the actions he's been taking
the entire time is not just the
impeachment it's the Middle East peace
plan it's what he's doing okay on
opioids it's us MCA it's Briggs it one
action after another okay
but Steve as a student of history which
I know you are noting this week bothered
you like yesterday when he we find out
now that he's you know the thing he said
about Comey we'll see what happens if it
was Obama people would be in jail VIN
demon gets frog-marched out
MIT Romney it's a suppressive person
this is very von stauffenberg isn't it
after the coup failed you don't think
it's an enemies list kind of situation
that doesn't make you a little nervous
you trust him with that power no
absolutely in fact here's what I've
argued from day one we should have we
should have a should have had a longer
impeachment we should have had Bolton
you should have had mauvais knee you
should have had all the OMB memos right
now witnesses let him get crossed but we
get the whistleblower we get the second
whistleblower we get shift as a factor
in this let's get it all out if this is
not and Trump says it's just not about
Trump this is about going forward the
office of the President if Bernie gets
in and you're as advisor
trust me the same things going to happen
if you think the neoliberal neocon
national security apparatus is it's
going to sit there and let Bernie as
commander-in-chief make the decisions
that he's empowered to as
commander-in-chief they're gonna fight
him every step of the way and that's why
this thing has to be vetted the the
abuses of the FBI in the CIA in the 50s
and 60s culminated in the church
commission in the 70s that's what we
need today i think the senate judiciary
committee ought to start calling
witnesses we gotta get to the bottom of
the 40 subpoenas that were out there by
the house intel we've got to get you
ought to declassify this cross for our
hurricane and let have let
bollam let Mulvaney let him all talk
let's get all the emails out there let's
see the whole thing okay when you say
crossfire hurricane the liberal audience
doesn't have the decoder ring for that
one that's that's just what that's
that's yeah but no they don't know what
they should listen this is about civil
liberal case it's about protecting the
office of the president your audience
should know that and that's why it's got
to be federal apparatus okay
I can't even but but let's go back to
history because he used words like scum
horrible people evil people he has a
different house style okay that's right
but we say excuse me we've seen this
house style before when you talk about
people like that when you're a cult
leader like that who was thousand
millions of wait a second he has
millions of people who would obviously
do anything for him and now we only have
loyalists in the government okay so when
you talk that's not true well that's
what people that's four people that's
where people were terminated today many
of the people on that list like because
they're just not loyalists they're good
people no it's not lawless remember a
course a commander-in-chief has the
rights the whistleblower and other guys
like that we're on the list that people
that worked around me put together in
April of 2013 these detailees a
commander-in-chief whether it's Bernie
Sanders AOC or Donald Trump have the
right to have horse around over that
believed and their policies their
program is like that loyalty okay these
are people who he didn't even know
existed they were deep state people deep
state meeting a competent people who
actually make the government work were
not or none not a believer in the
deceive let me get your question - yeah
because we have so much time okay
we've seen this in other countries when
you talk about people like they're scum
and they're evil we've seen it in Rwanda
cockroaches we've seen it in Germany
vermin you don't think that when you
talk about people like that your side
the people who hear those words you
don't think eventually it translates
into action they see people on Arsenal
as less than worth no absolutely not
why because we have the precedents I
just mentioned why is it not like you
don't stock roaches scum don't you know
listen you'll see nothing to say I don't
see any actions the deplorable Zoar
people doing that listen for the last
three years Nancy Pelosi in the
Democratic Party have sat there and said
we have to protect the country a clear
and present Donald Trump's a clear and
present danger against Russian oligarchs
the Democratic Party today is looking to
be saved by an oligarch this thing is
totally hypocrisy I'm at Bloomberg not
only Bloomberg American in moderate
public area America does have anyone
being a super rich guy when he's gonna
put billions of dollars to destroy
Donald Trump so they run against him
he's not running against him running
against what was he doing he's it's a
leveraged buyout of the Democratic Party
he's already said I will put two billion
dollars of capital and back of any
candidate to defeat Trump okay one side
always has more money than the other
this is not about more money it's not
about more money because the last time
Trump had way less money and he 1f sorta
you know why because Trump
it's only it's that mentality that has
you in this place today in the place
today as Trump is about to run the
tables you have a totally divided oh I
agree with that hello because nobody sat
there after 2016 and said why did we
lose the same arrogance you saw on the
people in Brooklyn that would not send
Hurley Clinton to Michigan and to
remember Michael Moore always makes the
point I think there's 70,000 ticket
votes in Michigan that didn't vote for a
president the reason is Trump reached
out to these working-class people
and connected with them okay and
included it's the same arrogance you see
in Iowa about this app yeah there is
that but we mostly lose because a
senator in Wyoming represents 290
thousand people and the senator here
represents 20 million that's mostly why
we lose the electoral college it's
called a republic so it's called a
public with a foundation okay
now is it really democratic sir for one
person to read love about you guys
you've got a whine about everything
whine the game hey the game is hate its
match play not metal play know when it
match I understand what the real good
what know you you know what the rules
are you guys wait you're right you're
right we should you're right you feel
the reefs should have gone to Wisconsin
you'd guess it's an electoral college
game I've admitted that many times
that's not the point you said why don't
you win you win because the game is
rigged for you I get it absolutely not
is absolutely not
with this attitude we're joining I know
we're gonna keep winning I love this I
know you guys how can you sit here how
can you sit here and have an oligarch a
Republican oligarch that is going to be
the salvation of the Democratic Party
okay it's outrageous you you guys have
secured well Bernie's been screwed by
the democratic party
he's look in the last week they wouldn't
allow the poll to be released where he
was up for okay then they do this thing
as soon as is it the whole debacle about
the county as soon as he starts closing
in the Democratic Party says hey let's
have a recanvass okay there okay Bernie
voters are a do what they did to 16
right had a belly full of the Clintons
come either don't vote or come vote for
Trump
I understand why you're against Bernie
yes I mean he is like too much so like a
lake burn really you want socialism
he's a populist socialist I don't agree
I don't agree with his solutions I think
a lot of I think it was kind of a big
part of politics no hidden oh the
biggest part the one the biggest part is
identifying the problem I think Bernie's
identify ways from pin him who shared
some voters because they both kind of go
after the same problem you're right
okay I'm just saying the Bernie people
are but help make Trump president you
don't want help making president again
even if you don't want then by the
Democratic Party I don't want that
amount of socialism I agree we need will
not agree I think we need some amount of
socialism I call it capitalism plus we
already have a lot of socialism but we
don't have a good form of capital okay
but we all a guard's and that are true
that Millennials are like Russian serfs
they don't own anything and they're not
going to own anything we have to we have
to redefine that that's the central part
that we have to but whose policies are
responsible for that this bait and
switch you guys pull all the time just
let me say
[Applause]
your Democratic Party is owned by Wall
Street in the corporate interest
oh god god forbid the corporate rivers
ever get their tentacles into the
Republican Party that would be a bad day
okay but let me ask you this who's the
real hits for years
who's the obvious problems and real
divided who's the real socialist Trump's
bailout of the farmers twenty eight
billion dollars Obama's bailout of the
auto industry was 12 billion why why is
it socialism when Obama does it but not
when Trump does it and why why is Trump
has run up a much bigger debt much
bigger deficits than Obama when the tea
party was out there what happened at
that why I think I think that the
solution to the rising debt is a white
president excuse me I think the solution
to the rising debt is a white president
because it was a terrible is it was a
terrible problem when Obama was
president now it is no problem Kratts
kids to get interested in deficits or
debt if you look at you look at the
monitor the modern monetary theory that
underpins Warren underplays Bernie
underpins a o-62 I'm looking at quantity
doing worse at it Trump's doing worse at
it but here's the right where's the
growth over time is going to is going to
bring down the deficit
for these tax cuts and pay for these
thanks God but you can't always try to
try to change the topic let's get down
to the basics you talk Trump all these
tricks like to always turn right yes you
did know a lot you know you know time in
the word populist ah you know people who
were against elites like you look at the
democratic form of the popular a light
remark look what they've done to the
populous state let me ask you this
question yes sir I read today some of
the things that he said about you over
the years just scathing I mean like you
know you the the word dog figures into a
lot of things and we see this look I
come from an Irish Catholic family with
five kids I've been called a lot worse
around the dinner table okay as I say
that's it's the signal in the north
that's all the noise that is a signal
look at the signal or what he's done he
says that whatever because he does this
constantly to people
he just says the worst things about him
they come back and eat his dog bowl no
why do they draws because he's a
transformative figure in his story is
that he is that we're going right into
dictatorship it's a very true it's like
the progressive left and 18:1 a big
because you went door to door they
understand that Donald Trump between
changing the federal judiciary
deconstructing the administrative state
is going to be in their personal lives
ten twenty and thirty years from now is
that is why the left that is why the
left goes door to door to beat him and
he's achieving his objectives
he said now comes the hour of action in
his inaugural address and you see the
actions coming together and that's why
we're sitting in February of 2020 he's
United his party
he's got the economy on his side and if
his best week ever that's what I said
okay
I wish we had someone on our side as
able as you Steve it's great to see you
thank you for going this
Steve Madden you can't get him down
you